it was a declaration of war on tax
havens around the globe
u.s treasury secretary general yellen's
proposal for a
global minimum tax on corporations has
met with approval not just from the imf
but especially here in europe and it's
causing some unrest in the caribbean
the british virgin islands are highly
prized by some corporations
the ones that shift profits across
national borders
into shell companies in order to pay
hardly any taxes
u.s treasury secretary janet yellen's
proposal for a global minimum tax rate
of 21 percent
was aimed at these companies washington
urgently needs additional revenue
because the pandemic is costing billions
the u.s
treasury loses nearly 50 billion dollars
a year to tax cheats according to the
advocacy group
tax justice network germany comes in
second and france is also among the top
losers
no wonder yellen is finding support in
europe
the u.s treasury secretary janet yellen
said yesterday that she's in favor of a
worldwide minimum corporate tax rate
this is a matter that i've been working
on for a very very long time
let's take the american 21 and use it as
a global minimum
tax rate and this could fly and also end
the business of tax havens
outside of europe as well as in europe
it's not only caribbean islands that are
among the world's most attractive tax
havens
eu members the netherlands and
luxembourg are also among the top ten
that's why eu parliamentarians like sven
gigold
are grateful for the support from
washington this is the moment we were
waiting for
and we will take your 21 and we would
support it as basis for a global deal
if they make that move we have a chance
that this will become
policy very soon because the public
budgets are empty everywhere globally we
simply need the money
and so the pandemic could now make
possible what seemed
impossible for decades reclaiming huge
amounts of tax revenue
chelsea delaney there in frankfurt
we heard amongst others the german
finance minister there who is more than
happy with the proposal
uh is europe however really united on
this matter and
what about the corporates themselves
what do they say
well the european heavyweights are are
certainly behind this idea france and
germany have been two
of the key forces driving the
this proposal for european companies it
would largely
be good many european companies pay
very high taxes here in germany the
average corporation pays around 30
percent
a 30 corporate tax rate so it would be
helpful to somewhat even even the
playing field
for these companies that are paying much
lower tax bills
other eu countries are likely to be more
resistant as
mentioned in the report there are some
eu tax havens like the netherlands
ireland
is also a big place where companies will
incorporate so those
economies do stand to lose out if this
proposal goes through
okay and there'll certainly still be
some discussions ahead to then
chelsea delaney in frankfurt thank you
so much
you